[MUSIC PLAYING]
Citizen A is a social
mobilizing platform
that helps citizens connect
to make changes in our city.
I thought of this
idea because we
were having huge
riots here in Brazil.
It was all over the
news in the world
that people were
complaining about the things
that the government didn't
do and just complaining
about the things and not
trying to solve them.
All of the riots began
in social networks.
So I thought, why not
build a social network
that people will
gather and do something
instead of just complaining?
So I had the support of
the City Hall from Rio.
They asked to give ideas
to build a smarter city,
and I gave this
idea to do this app.
And I won two prizes--
one for the idea,
and then I won a prize
for implementing the idea.
So now I'm partnering
with the City Hall
to build this platform
in the slums, too.
There are a lot of
people doing things,
but they don't know they
are social entrepreneurs.
So we want to build this notion
of social entrepreneurship,
and we want to help
people do more.
And there are a lot of
people doing things already,
but they don't know
people that are
doing things similar
to what they're doing.
So this is our
objective-- to show people
that there are people
similar to them,
and maybe they can join
forces and do bigger things.